Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
and ahhh
just checking in on you. Just checking
in on you. See how you're doing.
You having a good week? Hmm?
Are you enjoying yourself?
I hope you having a good fucking week.
Uh, I hope it's going better than my week.
I hope it's going better than my week.
Uh, uh, I don't know if I'll fuck it.
I'll get right into it. Uh,
unfortunately a, a great comedian,
great friend. Just one of the best people
I've ever met, uh, passed away yesterday,
Charlie Murphy and um, can't
fucking believe it, man.
Really cannot believe it. I had, um,
hadn't talked to him in about
a year and I had no idea that,
um, that he was sick
to that level. So, uh,
I think it's still hitting
me, man. It's unbelievable.
I'm so sick of fucking hilarious.
Great people dying.
I was actually talking with a friend of
mine the other day. I was just like, dude,
to hacks ever die.
Like what?
When was the last time somebody who
truly sucked at standup comedy died?
It's fucking unbelievable.
What a hex eat this. If I was,
if I had the fucking money, I swear to
God I'd get, I get to man, you know,
maybe it's all, you know, it's funny,
I actually realize halfway through
this and I'm still alive so,
and I kind of shitting on myself.
Somebody's got to put together
the hack diet, whatever that is.
Those motherfuckers
lived to be like 85 90.
Um, anyways, another just giant.
I mean you're talking about somebody who,
when I met him in 2004 had
already lived like four lifetimes.
He had four unbelievable books from his
childhood to his teenage years and early
twenties living in Brooklyn and all this
shit that he did to go into the navy,
to his brother blowing up and then him
getting out of the navy and working
security on the tour and then morphing
in to like a screen writer and actor.
And then he gets on the Chappelle show
to just was sitting around is what was
told to me. Just telling
these stories of, you know,
back in the day, hanging out with
everyone from prince to Rick James,
you've seen all those things,
stories about Whitney Houston,
he just sugar ray Leonard,
Oj Simpson.
He just like that sketch,
which to this day I'm telling you is I
think it's the greatest sketch of all
time that Charlie Murphy,
True Hollywood story about Rick James.
And uh,
I remember him telling me afterwards,
I was just like, dude, how true is
that shit? And he goes, well yeah,
obviously we exaggerate. Like, you know,
he didn't, when he hit me in the head,
I didn't have a unity, you know,
thing on my head. But he's like,
yeah he did. They were like in
the back of the limo or something.
And you know, Rick just kind of went
to, he was trying to be like friendly,
but I was like,
ah,
they kinda hit Charlotte like hard enough
in their head that I guess Eddie and
his friends were waiting for
Charlie react cause they knew her.
Charlie was Charlie Kinda got mind
fuck for half a second thinking like,
you know, I'd stomped the shit
out of anybody who did this to me,
but it's Rick James. And it kind of took
them like an hour before he was like,
fuck this. And uh, you know, obviously
didn't kick them up on a dresser,
but he did fucking rough them up
a little bit in the back room.
And then when the security came in,
he did bring them over to the window
and said that he was going to throw them
out. They came anywhere near him. So, um,
yeah, man, it's just really a really
a sad day. And that guy was just,
he was such a great guy.
I told you guys this story before
he saved my fucking ass one time.
Um, I was trying to get in shape,
right as always, as I always am.
I was living in New York City and uh,
I started going down to Gleason's
gym out in Brooklyn, you know,
cause I didn't want to get all fucking,
you know,
I was Joe billary swank is I believe what
I was calling myself or they will give
me shit cause I just went down there and
an actor performer kind of way to get
in boxing shape without ever fucking,
you know, getting my head kicked in.
So when I told Charlie that I was
going down to Gleason's gym, he goes,
I just to go going, oh yeah, okay, okay,
I'm going to tell you what's going
to happen because you can be,
oh they have about six weeks
and out of nowhere he goes,
some dude's going to come up to you
and start telling you and be like, ah,
how long have you been boxing for? Really
are man, you nice man. You know, Shit,
we had a spar some time. He
goes, he's going to fucking,
he's gonna amp you all up
to get you into the ring.
So he can try out a bunch of shit that
he does that he's not dumb enough to try
out on a professional boxer and he's
going to beat the fuck out of you.
And I was just saying, and he just
started laughing at me. I'm like, yeah,
I get the fuck Outta here. Get the
fuck I do. I'm telling you. I was like,
whatever time he said, three weeks or
six weeks, it was like right on the nose.
I'm sitting there,
you know when the heavy bag,
like the comedian slash sometimes actor,
I am hitting the bag like
[inaudible] right in this fucking,
this black dude shredded comes over.
He's like, Yo man. He goes, oh,
how long have you been a long
bit box before it was like,
it was almost like Charlie's
head was on the guys head.
He said the exact same thing.
Oh Man, you're nice man.
You gotta to get in the
fucking ring and all this shit.
And I just started laughing.
I just started laughing. I
was like, I go man, fuck,
I'll fuck. I'm a fucking comedian. Um,
horrific. I'm not getting in there.
So you can try out all your new shit on
me. And the guy just started laughing,
threw his head back, laughed,
and then walked away. And
it was so weird. I was like,
that guy was going to
beat the fuck out of me.
So then I told him to Charlie
thinking that he would be amazed
that you know, you know, like, like dude,
I called it, what the fuck did I say?
And he was just like, yeah, he's like, I
told you he did that like a million times.
Like he just had this, um, I dunno,
he had like this fucking 6 cents.
And I tell you some of those other
stories, the Oj one in the Whitney one,
but I just feel like those they hit,
those were his stories to tell and if
you wanted to share with me would have,
but um,
so I can only tell you the ones I
remember when we won that Chappelle show,
it was me, you know, Don,
Al Ashy, Larry and him.
And Charlie was the guy who actually
showed me that you could write a new hour
of material in two months.
Because I saw him do it
cause he blew up, you know, on
on the second season with that,
that Rick James Story
and um,
all this Darnell came up with the idea
for the tour. He was like, you know,
your son, we should go out
on tour, blah blah. So, you
know, we'll have bill open up,
you know, we'll bring you
out Charlie, you can host it.
And then Donna would close and um,
I think Charlie maybe did,
this is the fucking balls this guy had,
I think he did maybe six shows before we
did our first show and I believe it was
Dayton,
Ohio.
And we didn't even have an agent
and Donald book the thing. And uh,
so we went out there.
I was like the only white guy in the room,
in the theater and we went out there and
Charlie hosts anyone out and just went
[inaudible] you know,
uh,
I'm Rick James Bitch or something
like that place went fucking nuts.
He told like two more jokes brought me
out and everybody's looking at me like,
who the fuck is this guy? Is this one of
the writers? This is one of the creators.
Is this the agent on the tour?
Nobody had any idea who the fuck I was.
So I did my bullshit.
Charlie came out and told another couple
of jokes and then don [inaudible] close
to show. Everybody had
a great time. And um,
afterwards we went into the back room.
Okay,
now we're in the green room and there's
like 20 people in there and we don't
know anybody. Once again, I'm
the only white dude in there. Me,
Don Allen Charlia sitting at this table
and all of a sudden these two guys come
up. What was it? One
Guy, I can't remember,
and just had like a fucking bag
of cash from that night's Gig Ngo.
He had it all bandaged up and just threw
it on the table and it all spilled out
and it was just sitting there and I
was sitting there like, what the fuck?
And Don Allan,
Charlie didn't move so I didn't move.
And I was just sitting there
as a white dude, like going,
I guess this is how black
people pay each other.
Give them 20 complete
strangers in the fucking room,
drinking and partying and then just a
bunch of cash because I felt like we
robbed a bank or something.
So we sat there,
I swear to God for at least one more mob,
deep song of whatever the fuck was
playing at that time. The Thong Song,
I can't remember whatever it was.
And uh,
finally I forget it was either done l
or Charlie just soda casually sat up and
just took the money, put it in the
bag and then put it down by this side,
which made me relax a little bit more.
And I was just like,
I was sitting there going like, I don't
think I'm ready for this fucking tour.
This is not the way you
get paid at the funny bone.
So we stayed there maybe for like another
half hour and then we finally go up to
get up to leave and we're just walking
out and you just feel in eyeballs,
honest cause we got this big bay,
it's just cash
and we out go out.
We get into the fucking,
they had rented this fucking Limo Force.
We got in the car in the second the car
doors closed and we start driving away.
Darnell just goes, Yo, what the fuck?
And Charlie was just freaking out and
I just started and I was just like,
just the epiphany that they were actually
freaking out too. And I had no idea.
You'd never know looking at their face.
I'm sure everybody in the room knew that
I was fucking uncomfortable. And um,
suffice to say, after that we
got ourselves an agent and uh,
we got, we got paid by check after
that. It was just us in the room.
Um, and that was that infamous tour
where they would always make fun of,
that's where that Joe came from. You know,
this motherfucker got five shirts. Um,
that's where that one came from because
they always made fun of my clothes.
And that was that time when I was hung
over and I just didn't want to get in the
car and deal with this shit.
And they had taught me about the Itis,
which was basically when you eat like a
food that's rich in flavor but low and
fucking nutrition,
your body,
you end up taking a quick cat nap
cause your body literally has to shut
everything else down to figure out how
to digest what you just put in your
stomach. So I was standing outside this
hotel hung over as hell and I just saw,
oh my God, we were doing
that. He used to be the, uh,
it was the Chicago Zany and then
you do Mount Vernon. And then, uh,
Saint Charles who was his three
Gig run through Northern Illinois,
I forget where we go eat.
We just on detainees and I was too drunk.
I had a fucking headache. And I'm walking
out trying to get fresh air going.
I'm going to deal with these two fucking
assholes all the way up to this club.
It's a two hour drive. The nonstop
going to be fucking hammering me.
And I looked down the street and there
was a Popeye's and I just remember them
telling me about the itis and I said,
fuck this. And I went down there,
I got a bucket of chicken biscuits
with the mashed potatoes, gravy,
all of that shit.
And I brought it into the end of the
fucking limo and I was like, hey guys,
I got some food that Ah, Greg, you know,
and they dug and they started eating and
I didn't have one piece of it and swear
to God within 20 minutes they
were both asleep. And I had, they,
they slept the entire fucking
ride. I basically poisoned. Yep.
Temporary, well, he's in him and
it worked like a Goddamn charm.
And, um, I dunno, I just,
I had to say something about Charlie.
It's still too sad to really get into the,
the feelings all this, but
um, he truly was one, not only
one of the most amazing just
lives of anybody who ever lived.
He just was truly one of
the best guys that, um,
okay.
That I haven't met in
this business. So, yeah.
All right. That's it. No getting
emotional on the podcast. Okay.
So let's get back to the
rest of this stuff here. Um,
the fucking Bro, what's up? Finally,
the first time all year we beat
the auto was senators. All right.
Beat him when it counts.
Like I didn't even realize they
beat us all four times this year.
We'll congratulations Ottawa
capital of Canada, you know?
But unfortunately your full game
winning streak came to an end,
right when it counted. You got the
weirdest part of that game was,
was listening to a loud,
Otto was senator fans.
You know,
I actually know something.
I used to think that their
fans would just land.
But the real reason is Ottawa is
just like Washington DC, you know,
it's the capital. So there's a bunch of
people from all over the fucking country.
So there's a bunch of cannot fans,
flames, oiler fans, all I bullshit.
They're sitting there, they don't give
a fuck about the senators, you know?
So it's not the people, the
Ottawa, they're great people.
They got a little fucking river
that they freeze over. Yay.
Skate to work does not. They made, it's
like a fucking fantasy land up there.
It's one of my favorite cities. I actually
like it for some reason. They say, Otto,
we're the city. That fun.
Forgot. Well, you know what?
I always have a great time when
I write go there. Um, and um,
what a fucking great game though.
Ottawa play great.
I by no means think that victory means
that we're going to win the series.
I think it's gonna I
think it was two to one.
I feel like the whole series is going to
kind of go like that and it's going to
get even uh, not even shippy. I
think it might get a little ugly.
Um, Brad Marshawn back from his
suspension doing what he does.
Score and big goals and
big games. Um, hey nia,
come here.
I didn't know that. Brad
Marshawn. Where are you?
Yeah,
I had never heard this nickname.
Brad Marshawn.
They call them nose face killer because,
and I thought I was being so original
when I called that guy on a fuck.
That's because he sounds like Ghostface
killer. I'd call them pot roast.
Pot Roast. Face killer. Is that one
on one? Yeah. Here I am on my hat.
Look at that parallel thinking
parallel thought. There you go.
Is that what it's called? What?
Do you know what more than I do?
Is that what said behind my back?
No,
I'm doing all right. I'm doing
all right. The Bruins one.
I haven't been on the podcast in a while.
No, you haven't. Once you grab the mic,
grab a microphone. Come on
in here. I'll hit pause.
All right, we're back. I got the
microphone and everything like that.
The lovely Nia alo. How they hell?
Hell, how the Hell You Ben? I know.
Long time. No fuck no podcasts. No,
I don't think you've really
been on that much since. Uh,
we had the little princess here.
That's right. Who's sitting here.
You know what's funny is because you know
her hair still shorten everything and
all of our friends had boys and
they just gave us all their clothes.
Everyone keeps thinking it's a boy
and she just came in.
Now she's got a little shirt on that is
like a classic that looks like a 1955
Chevy pickup truck on itself.
Yeah. So a everyone, yeah,
everyone thinks that she is a buoyant,
but that's okay.
She will not be defined
by her gender, right? Yes.
She will put on a dress for God's sakes.
I liked the little play close though.
I think they're so cute. Well, yeah,
I mean I don't care either way. You
know you look good to me. That kiddo.
Yeah. She doesn't have to be like
all frilly and princess looking.
I'm not really into that anyway. What
are you saying? What do you mean? Well,
at some point you mean you've got to put
her with some girls clothes, right? Yeah.
I have plenty of girls clothes for her.
Okay. You scared me there. Okay. Why?
What do you, why? Why are you
scared? Well made at some point.
You can't say ever walking around
and like, you know Pete Carroll,
dockers and stuff. You know who
will now we're not going to do that.
But like I think cause
she's daddy's little girl.
Little girls look cute and like little
boy clothes, like the little tomboy. Look,
I think that's cute.
You know what is? Yeah.
As long as she has clothes on and two
diapers clean at this point, I'm happy.
Right. I believe, I don't care what
it is exactly, but now, so anyways,
she wore a cute little dress on
Easter, remember? Oh yes, she did.
[inaudible] she went to East to
west. So these two born it. Yeah.
Suddenly we go to church or anything like
that. We're heathens. Oh, by the way,
Leah, did I tell you about that
great band I saw the other night?
Oh you mean the one with
Dave [inaudible]? Yeah. Uh,
gave a ticket drum lessons from one of
the best drummers in the world right now.
Shout out to Davy.
That's right.
He plays drums in this band called the
night game. Or they have a new single out.
If you want to check it out its own
iTunes. It's called the um, yeah,
I'll field and uh,
I saw them play like a quick half
hour set the other night. Right.
Uh, over capitol records were
across the street from that.
Remember when I walked over and then had
my, my issue, have you done in x period?
Your issue? I've been doing cardio
like a madman. Maybe in some,
some readers can to ease of advice
about this. I blew cardio like a madman,
but like Jordan shorts on and I don't
know what happened. My balls, my ball,
one of them was just,
I just did too much walking in one day
and I had a little chafing issue on one
side of the old bag there.
And uh,
it did not affect my enjoyment of
the band cause the, I walked like,
it's like a two mile walk over
there or something. Right.
What are you doing?
You're looking at me or you're looking
at her two miles over and then two miles
back in that way after I'd already done
an hour of cardio. So the next day, uh,
I was walking like I wrote a horse for
like six weeks straight. But anyways,
I went over and saw this show and
they have a singer, rr Martin Johnson,
amazing singer, and then
two killer guitarist. I hope
they say these names right.
Uh, Karen, Jay,
you go colonian Max Bernstein.
And then they had a guy sitting in
on base, uh, Andrew Peruzzi and uh,
two days solid fucking admit.
It's really like poppy type stuff,
but the level of musicianship, how
great they all sounded live. Um,
definitely check it out.
Once again, it's called, uh,
the name of the band is the night game
in the single is the outfield and that is
out right now.
So can we talk about your chief balls?
Huh? Oh, it's done. It was just,
it was one and done was one
day of uncomfortableness.
Oh, you're okay now. Oh yeah.
Oh good.
Okay.
I was suggesting that bill get gold bombs
medicated powder because I just felt
like that was just something that you
just dust on your balls a little bit.
He kept saying,
you know,
like when those great chefs put the
powdered sugar on top of the confections,
do that little, no, I think that's
your balls a little bit to keep it.
That's not for chafing.
It's not, no, that's,
but I thought that's what people
who have itchy balls, itchy balls,
and they're sweaty and so therefore
it's all going have like a culture.
Like you're going to make bread,
but it's your ball red ball.
That's disgusting. No, this
is just a, yeah. Chafee,
you know what I mean?
Gary Chafee. All right,
chairman in here, the
third Mike. Um, anyways,
anyways, yeah. So that is uh, that is all,
but this is gonna be difficult and he
now when you know, we got the third,
but I don't know, well this is why Peter,
the heads me why, you know, on sweater,
like we haven't been on the podcast and
while, because they, you know, I have,
I have to watch her. Yes, she is. Look
how happy she is. She's such a happy baby.
I'm actually psyched that she's really
chill and so people keep saying she's a
really relaxed,
happy baby,
which is unbelievable considering she
lives with me and I've been doing,
I've been going really hard with
the whole trying to be chill. Right.
You want a good job? I'll go and
really hard with the Chili. Yeah. Hey,
go ahead and take it to the extreme.
I know you said to me the other day of
did you, have you been meditating lately?
That's what I know. I'm getting a little
up to the precipice there. Press a piece.
Yeah. So I got a, I got a fucking, I got
to handle that type of stuff. So, um,
hey,
the Celtics got the number one seat,
the number one lead number one seat in
the east. So we get some seed, s, e, e,
d c like what I put in you to have
that baby step. This is like, um,
this is, yes, that's a good point. The
balls are going to definitely be tough.
We're not trying to look
past him and, uh, it's just,
was a great night as far as, uh, you know,
considering the tragedy of yesterday,
the broads when the Habs lose weight.
But tell me what a seed is again,
just like, you know, they'll
have whatever, there's 10 teams,
you just ranked the number one seat
and each other the best record.
Why do they use the word seed?
You know what? I don't know.
All I'm saying that right. It's not easy.
Yeah. The number one seat. Yeah. The uh,
I don't know why they call it
that is what is the position,
what do you want to call it?
And then when you get to the class,
you're rewarded for having your best for
having the best record where number one
gets to play, the lowest person
that just made the playoffs.
So you get to kind of go in easier
way to go to class and it's also,
it kind of makes it so when you get to
the later rounds that the best teams are
playing in, the stakes are even higher.
This is to go to the NBA final. Gotcha.
This is to go to the, uh, you know,
this is the when the whole damn thing,
except in hockey, hockey of course they
do everything weird where, you know,
for whatever reason, um, like
Pittsburgh has to play the blue jackets.
And I would have thought that
I was like the capital's,
I would've thought they
would've got Toronto. I Dunno,
I don't get how they do it over there,
but that's definitely hockey. But we won,
we won the shit in a, sorry,
I'm all distracted today. Um,
I have to read some advertising. There's
anything you want to give me. Shit about.
My balls are better than it
was only one of them. Good.
Well I'm glad you used what I gave
you for them. And I'm also like a,
a a, a, I'm like a plane.
You know what I mean?
Like one of those big jet planes, they can
lose one engine still fly. So I'm fine.
I'm fine. Actually. I know. Why was
it only the one ball? I don't know.
Why is one ball vaguer than the other?
Is that why it's like rubbing
a little bit more? No.
Is it like how problem your
boobs are different sizes now?
It probably has more to
be with my awful posture,
my back being fucked up on one
shoulder in front of the other one.
I'm just a mess.
I'm all for all this year as a hanging
onto the anger and not stretching. Um,
just to twist it up, mess. But I'll
tell you, I have been stretching.
I would go to a chiropractor and of of,
uh,
I'm a sous regularly for almost like
a year. And had I not done that,
God knows what would have had,
I probably would have lost a nut.
Why still need to know.
Cause I asked you and you weren't
sure what a jock strap is used for.
Jock strap is using as a
cup now control it. It, it,
uh, it holds all your, your junk,
but just has no consideration
whatsoever for your ass.
I've never understood them.
I've never run a storm.
It's sort of the male thong. And if you
don't want like guy underwear lines,
I don't know why your ass is all the
way out. I don't know what it is.
I don't know what the fuck sports though.
It's called a jockstrap. It's for a job.
Well, let's look it up. Let's
have this on my search engine.
What's the deal?
What's the deal with what's with y?
Jock straps. Yeah. All
right. A jock strap is also known
as a Jock, jock straps, straps,
supporter or athletic supporter.
It is an undergarment for supporting the
male genitalia during cycling sports or
other vigorous physical activity. Oh,
it's a sports bra for your penis. Yeah.
For your junk. So now flop
all over the place. Yeah.
But evidently you don't mind if your ass
is hanging out and now commonly worn is
everyday underwear. Fashion jobs
perhaps appear in variety of colors.
Do they? You say dope when now you
got to go image Nia. Here you go.
Do you want to look at some designer
jock straps? I actually really do like,
oh hey. You'd go, wow, there's one for
you. It's a great asset. And that guy,
I'm like, God, that was like
reversed Victoria's secrets.
That was fucking horrible. All right. And
as your answer, if you had a nice ass,
it's like you have to have a nice ass if
you've got a model, those things, right?
Yeah. It's like if somebody
wants to look at, you know,
the same way a woman with the flat ass
and the Thong is one of the worst things
you could ever see.
Yeah.
You need to do literally see you
don't like it doesn't disappear.
You can see the hole.
He can see the whole thing.
MMM, that's right. All the
way to the front. Okay, well
I got to do some sort of a,
I've got to do a little reading out loud
and I don't want my daughter to know
how dumb I am.
So if you guys,
I'm not kicking you out but I'm just
saying if you want to block your ears,
ear muffs here. Um, you
read to her all the time.
He reached great. I actually do a good
job with those books, but you know,
he also ad Lib throughout the entire book.
Kind of like the way you do advertising.
You don't have to make weight links.
Let's was like this weird thing
where the guys, the ducks,
like an absent seat father,
he has like six kids with their,
he's that guy taken off going to Boston
common, I'll meet you over there.
I was like, I trust you. You're a good
mother. And she's just like, yeah,
well you know, I am. She did
everything but say, yeah,
this is where I belong.
And granted the book was working in
like the 30s to the forties and then the
little mermaid. Yeah, the
little mermaid anywhere. Yeah,
that whole thing was weird.
It's like she looks up love at
first sight with the prince. Yeah.
He's got his own Effient boat.
Can't curse when she's here.
I probably already did though.
Huh? That's okay. That's all right.
Nice little cutie pie girl. Kirsten. I
think it's hilarious. That warms my heart.
No. Alright. Upside everybody.
Okay, here's some advertising.
Sorry. Okay. Hey guys.
I discovered something really big.
I'm going to tell you,
I have no idea what this is,
so I haven't discovered anything.
I'm just reading this shit.
The best new way for you to buy travel.
It's called upside.com.
Here's why I love it even though I've
never seen it and why everyone I tell
loves it.
Every time you buy a trip at upside,
you save a ton of money and they give you
an Amazon gift card worth 100 200 even
$300 every time.
That makes no sense.
How would they make any money?
Like a plane ticket costs 300 bucks.
You get a hundred bucks back.
What are you flying people's express?
He on the old value jet there. The way,
uh, the way they do it is really clever.
Upside bundles,
your flights and hotels together for one
low price bundle prices saves money of
the how they do it. Especially
like giving you the secret formula,
especially on business travel,
so upside gives you
free Amazon gift cards.
I'm telling you,
if you're a frequent business,
if you're a frequent business travel,
your company saves a ton of money and
you can get f get thousands a year,
thousands a year just for buying your
air and hotel together at upside plus,
Oh God, this is so long. You still
get all of your miles, Jesus Christ.
These guys are given the whole thing away.
You'd be crazy not to check out
upside.com if you're shopping the business
pretty for business or personal travel.
It takes just three months to see how
much you saved by buying your flights and
hotels together at one low price.
I can't believe it's taken
this long for someone to do it.
Evidently possibly possibly discussed
speaking with Jay Walker here.
I've, I don't know who that is and
check out what I've arranged for you.
Use My name bur bur you're guaranteed to
get at least $200 Amazon gift card for
your first trip.
My name burpee you are,
gets you at least $200 in case you didn't
hear that two seconds ago on Amazon
Gift Card for free. How can you
not do it? It's a no brainer.
Save big on traveling. Get big
gifts. Sorry. They capitalize those.
A cart, a big gift card
every trip. Um, upside.com,
upside.com minimum purchase required.
See the site for complete details.
I've got to tell you, that almost
sounds too good to be true. Uh,
why would they want,
why would they give you all of that and
get you on the plane? Who's behind that?
Nia. Is it isis and I don't think.
All right, let me undies. Ah, oh yeah.
Get out of here for the song.
[inaudible]
me undies wearing a night
jock strap, Doo, Doo Doo,
Doo beyond ease me undies. Your balls
are fine, but your ass gets the clap.
Cousins hanging out for
the whole world to see.
They never see a junk unless you have to
pee by some me undies and the balls are
nice, you know, nice velvet rope.
It's like, you know what it is?
It's like when you're
wearing a jock strap,
it's like your junk is in VIP and
your ass is on the dance floor.
So in like, I love it. Hey Man, can I be,
can I get in there and pop some bottles?
All right.
Mandy's elevates your underwear game
to the next level with me undies.
You've perfected your wardrobe.
But what about this stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been
settling for store bought underwear,
five packs that a child put in there
at three in the morning in Honduras.
I have something that will change
your life for the better me undies.
What's the first thing you put
on the last thing you take up?
It's your underwear. Unless
you Matthew mcconaughey, uh,
make your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me on these.
What is me undies? What God's name
is it? Ah, just seriously soft.
Feel good and he's delivered right to
your door. Mandy's are designed in La,
Louisiana, Los Angeles, nobody knows and
made from sustainably source micro modal,
modal fabric,
three times softer than cotton,
allegedly Biondi softer than soft
luxury undies come in and ever changing
selection of classic colors,
bold shapes,
and adventurous patterns so you can
tailor your undies to your own personal
style. Amy undies, why don't
you make ya? Let's see your,
your take on the jock strap with your,
your modal,
your micro model,
just down modal tickling the taint.
And guess what?
You can save time and money each month
with a monthly subscription Indian.
If you're not ready for subscription,
that's okay. You can still save.
Relax. Let's, because we undies is
offering you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr and get
20% off your first pair. So go ahead,
revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it. Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burn me
undies.com/bar.
All right, Jesus Christ. Two
more to go. Hey Nia, have
you ever heard of legal zoom?
I have both. Good. You're fine. Monday
morning podcast. Oh, that was wonderful.
Number one,
reliability.
More than a million people have already
trusted legal suit to help start their
business and corporations,
LLCs, nonprofits, Tbas and more.
Use Legal Zoom to get
started the right way now.
But to experience you can count
on legal zoom for all the details.
They've been helping all types of
business owners for over 15 years.
They're not afraid. You walk in
a nother jackass with two arms,
put them in a shirt, go ahead. What should
deal? They'll handle it. Number three,
helpful support like a jockstrap.
They have the right people standing
by ready for your question,
all based in the u s America
making it great again.
Number four already.
Are there legal advice?
Legal Zoom isn't a law firm, but they
have a network of independent attorneys.
Ah, like better call Saul Old Joe to
Rosa crushing it on the first episode.
They can supplier contracts,
help with your employment laws and advise
you on many of the hurdles that pop up
when you're running a business. And
finally, number five, no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency
with upfront pricing, customer views,
and a satisfaction guarantee.
Checkout legal zoom today to see how they
can make life better for you and your
business.
And don't forget to enter bird checkout
to save even more legal zoom.com and
lastly, but not leastly a sweetie.
You might want some of these, Huh?
Huh?
You know she's got this new,
she actually has already figured out
how to make the pilot phase to try to
manipulate me to pick her up. And you know
what, God dammit. It works every time.
All right. D S T l jeans,
Delta, Sierra, tango,
Lima. Jane's great genes. Don't have to,
they don't have to be complicated
with number if you're not crazy.
It's a crazy stitching. Diamonds and
embedded studs. You're not alone.
I know they're taking a
shot at true religion jeans.
Are they still in business or now
they are. They must be in Charlotte.
That is still in business at like the
local kitty parks with those are dad jeans
now, right? They're all baggy and
shit and all that. It doesn't anymore.
Nobody wears. It's over.
There was only two cut.
There's only two people I knew that
bought those in my, in my, my cool,
rich vos rich vos and Bobby Kelly,
both of them,
they're into those disco clothes.
Designer jeans. Absolutely.
I think one of them had their name
in DMLS on the back of his ass.
I swear to God he did.
I think rich vice in the back of his true
religion jeans had first white guy on
def jam and genuine Diann Mills. Was He?
Was he the first white guy
on def jam and you just made,
that's what was on his head
shot when I first met him.
Pat hilarious was a picture of them doing
def jam. Oh, there you go. That's right.
To show you making history, breaking
barriers, right. Richard Vase.
This is one small step for a white man.
One giant leap for our white men
comedians. Ah, I Ms. Rich Vos. I don't,
I hope you hear this rich. Go Fuck
Yourself. He's not going to hear it.
He's out on a golf course.
Rich Vos has been like officially retired.
The way he's been living since I
met him. He lives the good life. He,
she goes more than Trump, by
the way. I love that term.
It's just golf in his ass off.
It's the greatest thing ever.
You can just show you how like,
like that job is not that big a deal.
Clearly not to him. Oh.
Oh, are you talking about,
you don't think Obama was
playing highlight? He played
some nerd sport. Yeah.
Avowedly basketball. No, he didn't.
He shot one free throw every election.
Every was like, oh my God. Hey
stabbing like he crossed somebody
over. Alright. Distilled,
pronounced distilled offers luxury
grade denim at an affordable price.
Jeans that would normally
cost you hundreds.
Dst GLD has at just 75 bucks
that utilize the same fabrics,
factories and wash houses as the best
known brands and designers while skipping
the markups and the middlemen. The result,
I was going to say, hey, you little kid,
what brought them
together? The result, pure,
unadulterated denim without
the retail run around.
Just go to distilled.com spelled d e s t
l d.com and see where minimalist design
meets maximum comfort. It's not like
you're trying to sell me a condo.
They guarantee the fit time sheer,
they'll shit.
They'll ship them to you for free.
That's what, that's what a jug strap is.
It's like a timeshare for your junk
up your ass. Debbie gets to the house,
they guarantee the fit,
those ship them to you for free and
give you free returns until you find the
perfect pair.
Dstl d distilled has feet been featured
in Forbes times and tech crunch as well
as on denim clad celebrities
in Gq and vogue or Jay Leno.
Who is it denim,
coed celebrity that you know,
John Travolta during urban cowboy
and denim clad celebrities,
New Light. They were done them all
the time. They're cladded in it.
Cladded clad distilled as the only place
in the u s you can get this quality of
denim for this price point. You can find
their amazing selections of outerwear,
leather jackets,
tee shirts in more using
the same principles of high
grade materials at low end
cost of a sudden I got the hiccups.
Even celebrities are wearing distilled.
Um, I've got a pair name, the gene
style and they've, the fit is perfect.
You know what, I can't fit in them
yet. Really? I thought you did.
Maybe I did when they first gave him.
Then I went up to a buck 90 when we
went over to Europe and it was smoking
cigars and he now stands look nice though.
I love those jeans on you. Oh, you know,
they're looking at better
folded up on my shelf. I uh,
I'm down to one 76 days ago. Yeah, that
was one 80 for a couple of weeks back. Um,
I'm a down eight pounds. Very proud
of myself. Even celebrity. Oh,
distilled is your answer to elevated
style without elevated prices.
Just go to distill.com/bar right
now and get 10% off your first pair.
That's distilled.com d s t l
d.com/bar for 10% off right now,
Nia do it. Let me hear
you. D S Now. Delta,
Sierra, Tango, Lima, Delta,
Nice Dotcom. Slash. Firm.
All right, look at that. 38
minutes went by just like that.
So that is the podcast are one
last shout out. I gotta tell Ya,
we low Wampler Jr. Remember that guy. Um,
I can't say fub was his song.
I know we've already dropped the F bomb,
but I'm trying to, I'm trying people. All
right. And he has a new album coming out.
Wheeler Walker jr his new album,
all wheeler,
all wheeler is coming out June 2nd
and can be purchased now on Amazon.
Prepurchase sorry.
On Amazon and on iTunes.
My birthday is June 2nd.
Really? What? When does
this album coming out?
June 2nd that's my birthday.
I always forget. I always
either thinking of, sorry,
the second or the third. Do
you really, is that true?
You're not that important to me.
Oh my God.
But you know what I used to think
of your birthday was on the eighth,
but we're not good with dates. No,
we're not. We don't do anniversaries.
Start when's are, don't
tell these people. But two,
can you name our wedding anniversary?
I always get confused. So do I. It's a,
it's fine if we tell them no. Okay.
Something has to be for, I have like, no,
somebody has to do for us Gary. Well,
whenever show pictures from it. Um,
so you don't know. I do. It's either,
is it start with a one or a two?
It does with the two,
but I don't know what
the second and never hit.
This is great because now I can
never get in trouble. You'd be like,
you're on the road on our anniversary.
It's like what did you look it up?
You don't even know what it is
and fairly certain
that I know it. Yeah,
that's it. Do you know it?
I had to think about it the other day.
Obviously we know the month, but yeah,
we got that going right. Does this
relationship work? I don't know,
but it's been going for 13 years,
so obviously we're doing something
right and we have this one.
You skated away from that really quickly.
Um, yes. Let's not try to analyze this.
Let's not pull any sticks out
of the popsicle house here. Um,
so what's going on today? Am I
watching her at all? Yes. When, um,
when a,
well,
you're especially watching her later
today while I get my eyelashes done. Cool.
You want to watch some playoff hockey?
The black cops are playing tonight.
There you go.
No.
And also why I take a shower and try
to feel human. Okay, cool. All right,
well that's it. All right. That's
the podcast, uh, for this Thursday.
Have a great weekend. And um,
that's it. Once again, checkout.
Um, all this stuff I told you to check
out that I now don't have in front of me.
Davey Litchi has banned the hell.
Did I say it? The nightlife.
Why am I the worst night game?
Night game.
Wheeler Walker jr his new album and um,
was that huh? Okay. That's
it. Like they get it.
We have a baby stuff and uh, yeah,
that's it. That would be the podcast.
I will check in up. Not Checking you.
I'll talk to you on Monday. Have a great,
great weekend. You see notes? I
can't say she's here. She's here.
Could you get out of the room please?
Yeah, so I can deliver my tagline.
All right. There they go. The
two beautiful lady already
to have a great weekend.
Guts. Hey, what's going on?
It's still paper and it is the Monday
morning podcast for a Wednesday,
April 15th. That's when I'm
recording this. Anyways.
And a buddy of mine tomorrow is going to
help me upload this fucking thing onto
my computer and then onto the GCAT thing.
And hopefully they did it.
And if they did, you're actually
listening to it, you know? And uh,
this is my new recording device. How
does it sound? Huh? You like this?
You'll like it to sound good. It's
stereo mother fuckers. Finally,
after years of you people bitching at
me about the sound of my cell phone and
you know, the tapping of my
computer and all that type of shit,
I am 90% there to have an,
a really great sounding podcasts.
I'm going all out, you know,
I'm getting a microphone.
This thing has the ability that you
can actually stick a cord in there,
have a microphone and a,
I'll be able to walk around like
Mike Douglas when I do these. And uh,
I think it's just going to help
the quality all the way around.
I hope it sounds good. I
hope that, uh, you know,
I listened back to a couple of years. You
can literally hear the echo in my room.
Um, because that's the way I
lived my life. Very sparsely,
very sparsely furnished apartment,
you know,
I uh, yeah, that's how I live my life.
I throw shit out all the fucking time.
You know, you ever see like these people,
uh, by the time they're 60 years old,
you know,
the fucking sleeping on their roof
because every time they went to a baseball
game and it was headband day,
they, they, they just took it.
You know, you don't have to take that
shit. I always just say I don't want it.
And they look at me like, what do
you mean you don't want it? I'm like,
I don't like clutter.
You know,
I don't need a fucking Baltimore Ravens
towel to wave in the fucking air.
I don't,
you know,
maybe I'll take it and hold jerk off in
the super eight later out. Bill. Why, why?
You know, it was so family friendly
right up until that moment. No,
I'm just saying I don't have a, I
don't have a lot of stuff, you know,
but the stuff I have as quality
and it means something to me.
I've noticed something about myself.
Anytime I say anything kind of sensitive,
I have to say it in a gay accent to
mask the fact that I feel uncomfortable
opening up, you know? So
anyways, let's get on with this.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
I do one of these every single week unless
there's a little sort of glitch with
my host, which is the first
time it's ever happened.
So just bear with me and just go with
this. I do one of these every week.
I think. I think I've earned the
right to say that. All right, Andy.
I answer people's questions. People send
me their list of overrated, underrated.
They asked me for advice for
some God knows reason. And, uh,
lately don't send
sending me a stories about revenge,
but here's a new topic that I
guess this guy was trying to say.
I introduced and I kind of
dropped the ball on it, but, um,
I dunno. This is pretty good. He's
talking about songs that annoy him,
which are basically any top 40 songs,
just songs you hear all the time.
And uh,
or maybe like,
I think the topic he was talking
about was annoying things in sports.
And I brought up how at
the red sox home games,
they play sweet Caroline. I believe
during the seventh inning stretch,
that's how much I hate that song is,
I'm a huge red sox fan and I
don't even know when they play it.
I believe that's when they do it. I
always just, I just turned the channel.
I can't, I can't handle it. And you know,
I know I'm from there and I don't,
shouldn't be trashed and red sox fans,
but I don't give a shit.
But if you go to Fenway park and you
start singing along to that song with your
arm around your girlfriend and y'all look
up in the air and you go, Bob, Bob, Bob,
you're a fucking embarrassment.
You were fucking embarrassments
stopped doing that.
Isn't it bad enough that we have
a mascot now for the Red Sox?
You know what I mean? Maybe it's
because I don't have any fucking kids,
but you know, can we be men, you
know, is that like against the rules?
Now do you know a long time ago,
I might have talked about this before,
but a long time ago,
back in the day,
I want to say it was in the 70s.
This is why the Internet is great because
you can look this up. I swear to God,
they tried to have a mascot.
Okay.
It was called the Fenway freak.
I swear to God. This is true.
And the thing lasted about three days,
three days in one trip
out into the bleachers.
And I don't know who that poor bastard
was that was inside that fucking suit.
But uh,
he got pelted mercilessly with any,
now that's back in the day when, when
it was bad day, you actually got a bat.
You've got a full size fucking bat.
They wiped out a whole acre of rainforest
for every fucking row of people.
And this guy got the shit kicked out
yonder. We got beat up. But he, you know,
it was definitely expressed that we
don't need a fucking mascot. You know,
this is back in the day too,
when a foul ball came into the stands,
he didn't give it to a kid.
You stepped on a kid to give yourself
another foot of height so you could steal
it from some other fucking guy. That's
how it worked, you know. But now you know,
we've got to give it to a kid.
Fuck the kid. Give it to a kid.
He did. He pay for his ticket.
Is He paid for parking? Hasn't
he gotten enough? You know,
you have to realize how lucky you are.
I was a kid.
You ever think about that
shit when you were like,
remember that when you were like six
years old, you just had no money.
You went outside to play with no ID,
no money,
no keys to the house,
just empty pockets and you just fuck it.
Went outside and somehow
you know it all worked out.
Try doing that as an adults.
Walk out of Your House without your keys,
identity or any sort of fucking money.
And I,
I challenge you to walk around the
block away from where you live without
collapsing in a full panic attack.
These fucking kids,
I don't know how good they got it and
they're going to get a foul ball on top of
it. Fuck you. God Damn it. I hate that.
Okay.
I Dunno. I Dunno if I hate kids or I hate
their parents. I don't know what it is.
I like kids. You know what I like?
I like a, I saw a kid the other day,
this toddler,
you know what's funny about toddlers,
you know when they're like two years
old is you know, parents always have,
I'm like running around shirtless. They
always have like that little beer belly.
It's the funniest fucking,
I cannot not laugh when I see that
shift because what I love is this.
So like not even self conscious,
anybody I was a gutter we subsidize in.
But when you're two years old,
you know, give a fuck, just walk.
They look like little truck drivers.
I just think the shit's hilarious.
So anyways, what am I
talking about? So, uh,
so this dude was basically talking
about, uh, just talk about, you know,
the new topic. Maybe it's
things that annoy you in sports.
And for me, I mean, I picked
on my own team, um, and I,
I also,
I think I mentioned,
I can tell that this guy
was bringing it up or if a,
I hadn't mentioned it before,
but let's,
I'll give him credit and agree with him
is when they have that old cop come in
and he sings,
God bless America in Yankee Stadium.
Like I've never wanted to throw a toaster
through a flatscreen more when he gets
up there and he does
that whole long beginning
[inaudible] and just fucking goes
on for like 19 minutes. It's Ah,
it's just the worst. Yeah. I, I dunno,
I hate that whole thing.
I will say hate how the Yankees
play New York, New York,
whether they win or loose.
It just seems bizarre to me.
And it was really funny the night when
the red sox finally beat him and hung the
biggest show can professional sports
history around their fucking necks.
And the second it's over.
The Red Sox had jumping all over their
field and that play in that fucking song.
[inaudible]
sat spread the news.
Is everybody up teary-eyed? I
don't, maybe it's a tradition.
I have no idea,
but I'm speaking of which ESPN recently
did a top 25 chokes of all time and the
Yankees of 2004.
We're nowhere on the list.
They had like Greg Norman.
I was really surprised by that.
But I guess it's because you know,
when you dominate an entire century,
you know, eventually you're going to have
a bad year. So I kind of understood it.
And of course the red sox made the list.
I think we were a number seven through 18.
I think we were the top.
We have the top 11 fucking
jokes of all time. Um,
but anyway, speaking of that, did
anybody watch the masters? I actually,
uh, played nine holes
of golf, a par three.
And I've never given a shit about golf.
I never kept score.
I used to sneak into a private golf course
when I was a kid with my buddy during
the wintertime.
You know,
when it was no snow on the ground and we
would play golf, but it was more like a,
it was more like Polo, you
know, it wasn't a stroke thing.
It was more like a who could
get the ball in the hole first.
So there was a lot of uh,
you know,
standing in front of somebody off to the
side as they were shooting and you were
shooting two and he fucking slices it
in the hitching your back. Uh, you know,
that kind of shit.
And then you play like five holes and
then you don't give a fuck and then you
just start trying to drive golf balls
at the building next to the golf course.
We played golf like that. So
anyways, long story short, uh,
I actually had a good time on this par
three course and I actually part one of
the holes and I started to be like,
man,
I think I might want to play this
fucking game. So I got fucking,
I'll watch the master's, I'll
see what's going on. You know,
I bet a little money with my good friend
Keith Robinson, who a, he's part of my,
my, uh, I think he made the first row
of my top 9,000 friends. And, uh, he's,
he's a man of African
descent, so, you know,
I'm sick of them talking about tiger
woods and I'll fucking Grady is and all
this shit. So I call up Keith and I
tell them that, you know what, I'm,
I'm willing to bet against tiger.
I'm willing to put my money on a
fucking white man to a beat the,
uh, tiger woods, you know, so he goes,
I'll take it if at 20 bucks I picked Phil
Mickelson and I beat that motherfucker
by one stroke.
So anyway,
so I get totally into this master's and
I'm watching the end of it thinking it's
going to be this very cool thing.
It was the most unsatisfying winning of
a championship I've ever experienced as
a fan because the Guy Kenny Perry,
48 years old, he had the
fucking thing one. Okay.
He burned, he's 16. He's up by
two strokes with two holes to go.
He bogeys 17th.
Bogeys the 18th and then
loses a two round playoffs.
It was,
it was one of the saddest things
I've ever seen and it's like,
what I really realized is golf is the
worst sport to choke in because you choke
in anything else. Let's take the red
sox. The ball goes, who bucked is like,
how long did that take?
How long did that take?
Like what fucking two and a half seconds,
dude.
This Guy Kenny Perry
choked for like 90 minutes.
An hour and a half on national
television, slicing it, hooking it,
going into the trap in front
of his whole fucking family.
The show in his family
that dying a slow death.
His fucking wife couldn't
even look at them at the end
of it. It was just, it was,
it was fucking horrible. I actually woke
up the next day thinking about going,
God,
if he just chose a different club.
I don't know if you're a Kenny
Perry fan or, you know, I,
I feel real bad for that guy was one of
the worst fucking things I've ever seen
in my life. So I don't think
I'm ever going to watch golf
again. I'm done with it.
Although I might start playing it and
thus complete the circle of being a a a
white man, you know? Isn't
that what I'm supposed to do?
Cross my legs with penny loafers and
start pontificating like I know how shit
works as I wait to tee off isn't the
one I'm supposed to be doing. You know?
Certainly by the time I'm 50 dress like
I'm in the in a three stooges sketch
level.
They always do address like in there
in the 1920s and they were one of those
black panther berets, but it has
a palm palm on it. All right.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about. Let's get back to this kid's list.
This kid made a list of
his top eight which I love,
who if people do a top five top three
top 10 who does a top eight I'll tell you
who this motherfucker,
he's doing his top eight songs that just,
he never needs to hear again. He
basically said, if I were all powerful,
I would begin by outlining these things,
which I think is a great new
topic to another new topic. Okay?
Not only do you got the things
that annoy you in sports,
how about what if you were a
dictator and you could make laws?
What would you outlaw? And
this, he's, this kid's just
going with music. All right,
number eight. He said, sweet
Caroline, as I just went off on,
um, number seven, hotel, California.
He goes, I don't give a shit
where you're living it up.
You overrated Pansy. He's got a lot
of anger towards all these artists,
hotel California.
Can we,
can we admit that that song
never needs to be played again?
Piano man, horrific song,
horrific song. He know.
What's the worst part of the song is?
I think it's in three four isn't it saying
[inaudible] two, three, one, two, three,
one, two, three, one, two, three, one.
And everybody starts fucking
rocking back and forth.
Like the Red October fest as
that's the fucking, you know,
it's a great moment in a
bar and I swear to God,
it's right out of a Benny Hill sketch.
You have see somebody with a beer in
their hand and they check to see what time
it is and their watches on the
same hand is, it's never not funny.
I saw a guy we would drink
and after an la kings game
and you don't like when you
go to make a point like,
you know what the fuck can you kind
of throw your hands out to the side.
He did that with a full bear in his
hand and literally just threw like,
it looked like a lake of bear onto this
table where there was like, you know,
three women sitting at, which made it
even funnier. You know what I mean?
Cause they were all just like, well
I never, um, anyways, anyways, let's,
let's continue weight number number five,
living on a prayer.
Absolutely. I would say the entire
Bon Jovi catalog other than,
uh, that wanted song, that's a guilty
pleasure. It's on my fucking iPod.
I'm not apologizing for it.
And I actually learned how to play
the beginning on the guitar and uh,
and it made me happy.
I'm such a fucking loser.
All right. Number four,
sweet home Alabama and it's
still one that's on the fence.
It's such a good fucking song. But yeah,
they've really played the hell out of it.
And I love how, uh, I think
somebody wrapped over that.
I think I talked about this before.
Some rapper rap to that sample and it's
been in a couple of movies and I noticed
black people kind of start bobbing their
heads when that song comes on. And uh,
if you're black,
you should really look up the lyrics
to that song and I don't think he'd be
bobbing your head. You'd
probably be shaking it. Um,
all right. Number three.
Mustang Sally. Yeah,
that song's for like cougars
chicks to start fucking shaking.
They're dusty muffs too.
You know,
it's a grind up on some fucking 20 year
old kid who really wants to bang you
because he's got some sort of weird
issue with older women because his mother
didn't stick around. That whole cougar
seen is just the creepiest, it's,
it's every bit is creepy is the 50 year
old guy date and that the fucking 18
year old chick, that whole
daddy thing going on, it's just,
it's really a, it's creepy,
but I'm not gonna lie to you.
If I was 50 and single and I
could, ah, how long would you go?
Do you ever think about that?
Like right now I'm 40
going to be 41 in June. Uh,
25, 25 is my cutoff. Uh, maybe 24.
She listened to jazz.
She seemed mature.
Um, yeah. All I know is
you can't be in college.
I remember one time when I was 35,
I hooked up with a 21 year olds in,
in the process of air
quotes here seducing her.
I actually said, so what's
your major? And I almost,
I almost pulled the plug right there.
But fortunately my dick was running
things at that point and I was able to see
the mission through. All right,
number two, uh, brown eyed girl.
I don't mind that song. Fam Morrison,
you know, maybe it's, is that
Fan Lorcen Jamar Brown? I do. Do you
remember when? Oh yeah. You know,
that's one of those songs that everyone
sings in a bar and it just makes you
hate humanity.
I'll give you that one.
And is number one song is a American pie.
Oh yeah, that's the, that's a song that's
like really dramatic for no reason.
Even though I know this,
they're singing about, uh,
the big bopper and Ritchie Valens
and a buddy Holly all dying.
This wasn't the guy to do the song.
He just,
he just really slow. And you know, Madonna
did a cover, that song. Talk about,
you know,
two horrific worlds colliding.
I'll tell you this, if I, if I
could, if I could pick my top,
I'll just give you my top three.
Um,
number three is the
entire beyond say catalog.
And that includes all of her work
with destiny child, Destiny's child.
I think she's a beautiful woman. She's
a great dancer, but she cannot sing.
I think she's singing too high and then,
and then it's just, Ugh, those fucking,
I haven't heard hooks like that since
the last time. J Lo had a fucking album.
I'll I that song she had out and they
just kept playing that saxophone over and
over again.
Nah, Nah, it, it did. It did. It
did. It did. It did. It did it.
And you just wanted to fucking smash
or glass into the person next to you.
Like they like punish you with the music.
That's what like Beyonce songs are
like, I don't get it. Like Beyonce.
Sing as high as you can and then sing
the same thing over and over and over and
over and over again.
Be like an 80 man. Hey Man. I
mean, 20 minutes later, hey,
ugh,
all her beauty goes down the
fucking drain. The second
she starts singing Jesus,
I'm in a mood. So all
her entire catalog, um,
anything by kiss. And I'm going to
pause here to let everybody be like,
oh Jesus Christ. Kids. Come look
man. Just Guy Detroit, rock city.
It all sucks. It's horrific. And you
can take fucking Bob Seger with them.
It's a lot of bad white music coming
out of Detroit. I'm telling you.
Um,
and the number one would be thin Lizzy.
The boys are back in town and uh,
they should be like a contest.
Like to just see how long
you can listen to that song.
It's like they just singing
about these fucking,
this group of Douche bags that just
like thinks they're bad asses. I guess.
You know, I haven't, I talked about this
before. I can't even fucking remember.
I've done some of these podcasts.
They got the,
the boys are back in town and
they get that hope the ball.
If the boys want to fight,
you better let them really or else what
you know
man, man, that chick slap Giani in the
face. Man, we fell about the place.
You know, like everyone's just sitting
around this town waiting for these fucking
douchebags to show back up. You
know, come back into town, you know,
all fuck the boys are back in town,
hide the women least fucking nerds are
back in town and if they want to fight
you better.
Let them,
whoever wrote that song should seriously
consider killing themselves. You know,
it's right up there with Woodrow Wilson
Pushing through the Federal Reserve Act.
That's number one. And number two is
whoever wrote the boys are back in town.
That's how I see that shit. All
right, so let's move on here.
Let's get on with the podcast.
Uh,
what do we got here and what
do we got here? All right.
This here is not really a revenge story.
This is actually a,
dare I say,
kind of clever.
What this guy did to fuck somebody over
he a, this is what he did. He took us,
I don't know a lot of this computer stuff,
so I'm going to try to read
this slowly and God knows,
we all know I suck at reading out
loud at this point. All right.
He says, uh, I took us.
Basically what I did was I took a screen
capture of my friends desktop when he
left his computer on attended,
which basically means he took a
picture of, of the guys desktop.
I guess he didn't have anything on the
screen. He just took a picture of it.
He goes,
I then hid all his desktop icons and set
the background as the screen capture I
just took.
So basically it looks like all his,
all the folders and icons are still there,
but they're not.
So when the dude comes back,
you'll be clicking till his fucking mouth
start smoking and nothing will happen.
May come on, man. You gotta
give this guy an a for effort.
That's, that's pretty, uh,
I think that's kind of ingenious. So
anyways, I guess this is how it plays out.
He goes, I waited for the guy to
return to see his reaction. He goes,
I stood off in the distance,
like a fucking stalker. He goes,
at first I could see the really
confused look on his face,
but it very quickly turned to
frustration and then anger.
He began mumbling shit
like fucking piece of shit.
And it escalated to him pretty
much yelling and saying,
I'm going to smash this mother fucker.
He goes, I couldn't believe it.
He was pounding the keyboard and slamming
the mouse. I was laughing so hard.
That's not what's coming out of my nose.
So they do concluded that he had a virus,
soy.
He took the computer to the it department.
They figured it out in five minutes
and told him he's an asshole.
What do you think that I do? Good. Or Am
I the Douche bag of the week now? Dude,
you did great. That's fucking
hilarious. That's a great idea.
I wish I knew something about computers.
I would try that on somebody.
I tried that on my girlfriend.
That's the kind of guy I am. Um,
no, you're not a Douche to, that's a,
I don't know if he came up with that,
but that's pretty, uh,
that's pretty ingenious.
So I gave you a thumbs up on that
one. And everybody at work, go ahead.
Go try that on your boss.
No,
I don't do to your boss because some will
end up ratting you out. And eventually,
even if they didn't rat you out,
they could figure out that you were
the one who did it because you would be
doing that. You know that laugh and you
didn't in school when you were a kid,
you weren't allowed to laugh
and you would hold your nose.
So you'd start making those duck noises.
That usually gives away that you're
the one who fucking did it. All right,
let's get on with revenge stories. Um,
before I get on with the revenge stories,
uh,
some woman was letting me know why
females are better at revenge than guys.
And she wrote a pretty interesting
thing here. Uh, she says,
cause I guess I was asking all my uh,
podcast a couple of weeks ago,
how come his revenge only a guy thing?
How come I'm not hearing from women?
And believe me, if you hear
the stories this week, uh,
I really opened the floodgates because
the f the, the women, the ladies,
they came in strong this week.
So before I read all the women
revenge stories here, uh,
this woman has this, a little preamble
setup she gives me, she goes, Bill,
you've only read one revenge story
from a female. And I'll tell you why.
Guys are idiotic and deal with anger.
So stupidly
is stupidly a word.
Is it a geyser idiotic and they deal
with their anger in a stupid way.
I don't know. I'm too fucking stupid
to know, but that would be hilarious.
If stupidly is not a word,
you know,
because you just made yourself look like
an ass and if you didn't, I apologize.
Let me continue. Uh, fucking
up. Someone's car is pathetic.
This kind of revenge is temporary.
Doing something like that would just
make someone think of you as a cock suck
and jackass and then I'll
move on with their lives.
Women can and will remember my new details
and situations that guys will forget
when we want to know, wait,
when we know how someone works,
we know how to use it against them.
Physical is temporary.
Psychological is permanent.
Women can do the most damage
with the least effort.
We don't aim to screw someone over or
to do something to piss someone off.
We aim for resentment.
Resentment is much more powerful because
it places you in a higher status and
when someone resents you,
it's most likely that you have something
that they don't and that you are just
better than them.
In some way.
So my point is that lashing out at
someone as stupid and only makes you feel
better and doesn't really
have or accomplish much long
time effect on the other.
All right, now I want to
tell you something, you guys,
that paragraph right there is why I've
never gotten married because I realize
that women have that, you
know, they got that in them.
You know that expression Hell hath no fury
like a woman scorned. That's the deal.
It's this weird thing that when they're
dating you and they want to know
everything about you,
it's this odd thing where half of it is
so they can love the whole you and the
other half is like, it's collateral
in case the thing goes bad.
They have all this fucked up information
that they can use against you. So, uh,
I don't know, that was pretty
chilling to read that. And uh,
I don't agree with their definition of
resentment saying that it, it, it, uh,
it means that you have something that
they don't or that you are just better
than them in some way. Uh, I don't think,
I think they resent you because
you fucked him over, you know,
not because you drive a
better car. Right. I Dunno.
Why don't I shut the fuck up and read
the first revenge story? All right, his,
now this is all from the,
this is all from women this week.
And I gotta tell you something.
They really, really take
it to the next level. And,
uh, yeah. All right, let's just get on
with this. All right. And, uh, this one,
I'm not going to tell the street. There's
a couple of names and street names,
and here I don't want to get
anybody in trouble. So here we go.
Fill this story is actually not mine,
but, um, I was a participant. Um,
you know what?
I'm going to say the name squeeze.
I'm not going to try to
fuck remember fake names.
I'm just not going to say the
name of the street. All right.
Right after I graduated from
college, I moved to, okay.
I can't say that my roommates
were still college students,
sometimes their friends,
which were also my friends,
we all went to the same college. They'd,
uh, they'd stay over. One of our friends,
uh, Jess, who still lived in the dorm,
was having problems with a roommate. Gale,
her roommate knew she had
an eating disorder and was
spreading rumors about her
writing things on our
mirror, like, you're fat.
We let just stay at our apartment. And
we started plot, started to plot revenge.
One of the things we did was crank called
gale. So in case you got lost in that,
I guess Jess is the anorexic one
and Gail is the content. All right.
Okay. Let's continue on. One of the
things we did was crank call Gail. We,
we use the voice from my roommates Mac
computer and typed out some evil shit.
There's definitely made,
just feel better and I guess inspired
her to pull the ultimate revenge.
Jess was a team model before she went
to college. This is the anorexic girl.
While in college she
worked at a high scale,
a high scale salon on something,
something street.
Shortly after we crank called Gail just
ran into gales boyfriend after work.
According to Jess, she brought Gail's
boyfriend back to her. Their dorm room,
fucked him in Gail's bed and then called
Gail right after to tell her all the
details.
Just ended up staying in our apartment
the rest of the semester and bought us a
$200 bottle of champagne to
celebrate the act of revenge.
At the time, I thought Gail got
what she deserved. But in hindsight,
it made me realize that women are
evil, manipulative bitches. Yes.
Many women hate being called fat,
but it ceases to amaze.
But it never ceases to amaze me that
women, what women will do to others,
other women to get back him.
Wow.
You know what I mean? They
take it to that level. Uh,
I don't know who deserved
what in that story,
but I think the real winner
is a Gail's boyfriend.
You know,
you have a one that if you're a guy,
you ever wonder if any girl was fucking
you oughta revenge just to get somebody
back. You know? I don't think
that's ever happened to me.
I don't live that exciting a life,
but I can't imagine
what is, what do you say is the guys,
she's sitting there banging you. Yeah.
That'll show her flip over
and I'll bust it on your face.
You really taught her a lesson.
Hey,
anytime you want to teach and teach
her a lesson again, just let me know.
I really, I really, I'm
really down with you.
I understand your point here and I
think you're very justified. You know,
you know, really make really drive
the point home is you, let me,
if you let me bang you again,
you know,
and did you really want to get
the ultimate, ultimate revenge?
You'd let me put it in your ass.
You know,
I'm just throwing these ideas out there.
I mean, this is, this is your world,
you know, I'm just, I'm
just here to help. Okay.
So that's revenge story number
one. Um, and I can see, you know,
in order it is, it's not that
she's fucked the girl's boyfriend,
it's that she called him up.
I called her up and told her about it.
You know, that's one of the advantages
of women is for the most part,
they don't have to worry about the other
woman coming over and just beating the
shit out of her.
Because as a guy,
if you ever tried to get back and another
guy and you banged his girlfriend,
you'd never call the dude because I don't
even care if you could beat the guy in
a fight on a normal basis.
You know what I'm saying?
The level of anger that he would have,
he, I think he'd still win. Right?
Does that make any sense?
All right.
Let me plow ahead at Jesus
already up to 31 minutes.
Let me get through these here. All right.
Hey Bill, here's my story of revenge.
Everybody knows that women hate
each other, hate other women.
And I have a great story
about women's revenge. Um,
I was roommates with two
other women in college.
One was very average looking
and one was very beautiful.
The type of beautiful that makes all
the other girls around our hater.
Um, she got whatever she wanted throughout
her life because of, because of it.
Guys, money, grades, you name it. And she
was a bitch. She used everyone around her.
It was never said no to.
Um,
so I was casually dating a guy
and brought him back to my house.
So both my roommates were there.
We hung out with them for
awhile and everything was cool.
I didn't notice anything unusual.
A few weeks later,
or a year from a mutual
friend and my roommate,
I guess the hot one was out with my guy
after seriously interrogating my guy,
he finally spills his guts
and tells me the truth.
I would have loved to have seen
that guys have the worst liars ever.
No one was the to doing
fucking 12 seconds later. All right. All
right. You got me. I was fucking her.
Anyways, he goes, uh, she had, uh,
the hot girl had bumped into the,
her boyfriend on campus one day and I
guess they hit it off and started seeing
each other by my back.
Um,
naturally I dump his ass,
but I'm so much more pissed at her.
I kinda read that weird. So it's her
boyfriend. Um, okay. So anyways, uh,
I come up with a brilliant plan to get
my revenge on her and enlisted my other
roommates for help.
She agrees because all average
girls secretly hate pretty girls.
This is really eye opening about the,
uh,
these psycho inner worlds of women. This
is like an HBO undercover. So anyways,
here's that revenge. Uh, we had an
an advantage because the hot girl,
she drank a lot and we'd get ripped almost
every other night and I mean really,
really ripped. We'd
wait until she gets, uh,
so one night we waited until
she got loaded one night
and it was the most wasted
I've ever seen her. It was like all
the stars were in line for our plan.
She had beautiful long corn.
Silkair uh, oh, here we go.
Here we go.
She had beautiful long corn.
Still Care was straight off
the ass of a golden retriever.
I bought two boxes of black hair
dye and after she passes out,
we start in.
I really wanted to make a statement,
so I part her hair down the middle
and only die half of our head.
Jesus Christ.
After I start,
I turn into this crazy die hungry freak.
I couldn't stop myself.
I started dying. Any part of her
body that could, that I could find.
I did our eyebrows,
the peach fuzz on her chin and
lip her fingers and her arms.
I'm embarrassed to say that we even died
a lightening bolt in her pubic hair.
The funny part was is she kept waking
up telling us to leave her alone,
but we kept going. Jesus, this,
this sounds like a fucking date
rape story. It's just that as women.
So I guess is, it's still funny. Anybody
else getting creeped out here? Um,
let's continue here. Of course,
we were too lazy to wash it out,
so if we just go to sleep and leave the
black hair dye on our roommate for about
seven hours, I wake up the next
day to her in a towel towel.
Her hair was soaking wet and she was
beating the shit out of me with a shampoo
bottle.
It was fucking hysterical.
The dye had stained or
skin along with their hair.
So she had dark brown patches
all over her face and body.
She looked like the bastard child of
Cruella Deville and Richard Grieco.
I don't know who that is.
I was so proud of my work.
You would think that I got my revenge,
but this is a story
about her revenge on me.
So the fucking long one here,
plot twist,
she actually called cops and they fucking
came and arrested my roommate and me.
The evidence was stacked
against us because our hands
and arms were also stained
with black hair dye.
Her bed where the crime was
committed was covered in black dye.
It looked like an octopus
had been raped in there.
She tried to charge us with sexual
assaults. Pump a pubic hair,
lightening bolt. Yeah. You know,
you pull somebody's pants down,
start dying their genitals
or at least the area. Yeah,
you're going to get in trouble.
So anyways,
after spending all day
in the police station,
we were finally let out and
the charges were dropped.
But when we got back to the house where
you're greeted by campus security and
our parents were there too, trying
to explain to your dad why you died.
Some other girl's pubic hair,
not fun.
The fucking bitch got is kicked out of
the house and we put on strict probation.
It was a big deal. We almost literally
almost got kicked out of school.
The worst part was when we
were moving out of the house.
About a week later she shows up with
my ex boyfriend and she looks amazing.
She had died the rest of her hair black
and cut it in this cute short Bob style
and whack stuff. All the body
hair. She was as beautiful as ever.
And then she writes in capital
letters con I felt like such an ass,
like there was no way to get back at
this bitch. I guess my life isn't over.
So someday I will get her back.
I'll make sure to fill you in.
Okay,
well I know you haven't asked my advice,
but uh, I think you should just let that
one go there. A sweetheart. I think,
uh, you know, sometimes
you just gotta say fuck it.
Uh, isn't that unbelievable? I
mean, things like reverse that.
And if, if you, if you did that as a guy,
if you did that same thing as a guy,
you would literally be in a prison
shower right now with half a mop handle
trying to fight off five rapists.
But if you know you have a vagina,
all you get it,
you just get kicked out of your house.
Fucking incredible.
I still a bit about that shit. How having
a vagina just keeps you out of jail.
You know, like, like you have us, he
like when a mob boss gets arrested,
you know, they never
take the wife, you know,
like she doesn't know what the fuck he's
doing. Oh, I just thought he was a baker.
I thought he was really,
really good at making cookies.
And that's why I had 20 furs and
lived in a, lived in a mansion.
You knew what the fuck he was doing,
you know,
and you spent all that blood money in
you and you don't end up fucking going to
jail. It's a, there's something
about it. Like they just don't, uh,
like remember that movie monster's ball,
not monsters balled up monster with eight,
literally turned a serial killer
into this sympathetic fucking person.
I just didn't, you know. Yeah. He
had a rough childhood. You know,
you got molested. What are, you know,
who didn't go right? Some fucking jokes.
You don't get a gun. And starts
shooting fucking people. And if you do,
you go to jail.
They don't ever see that movie was the
worst fucking movie ever with those
cartoon character,
male characters that they had in that.
Did you see?
You remember that part where she goes
into apply for the law office job or
something? She comes in there
looking like this strung out hooker,
and somehow she's not ushered
right out of the fucking office.
She actually gets in to the
lawyers office and he's just like,
let me tell you something. You fucking
skank. He's like, there's over the top.
I really hated that fucking movie.
Kind of hate when beautiful actresses
don't wear makeup. And then the,
everybody falls all over themselves
and talks about how brave it is.
He was so brave. He was
so brave. All right,
let's continue on here. All right. Let
me read the last one here at bill. Uh,
for the past two weeks I've made my
girlfriend listened to your podcast.
Incidentally,
she loves it.
This past week she told me about how
she got revenge on her ex boyfriend off.
This one is brutal and it's,
it's very, uh, there's,
there's no fat on this one.
This one's great because she doesn't
get caught. There's nothing, you know,
I don't wanna ruin here, but just listen
to this. After that messy breakup,
she logged onto their shared
jet blue, a cow, you know,
they're going out. You know,
I give a deadly that taking trips.
So they got this jet blue account and they
evidently, they both had the password,
so she logs onto it and she saw that the
Douche bag and his new girlfriend had
booked a vacation.
Well,
the morning of their scheduled trip
on the morning of the scheduled trip,
she logged on and canceled the flight.
Can you imagine what a pain in the ass
that must've been for them anyways,
she never saw any activity
on the account again.
I thought that this was pretty funny. A
lot more subtler than king someone's car,
like a little bitch and whatever
and whatever. That other more on,
wait,
I'm reading this wrong and whatever
that other more on girl did on the other
weeks podcast. Wow, man, that is
dead is dirty pool right there.
If the guy cheated on
you, yeah, I can see that.
But if you just had a messy breakup,
that's uh, that's vindictive.
That's really fucked up.
A lot of these things are
really a really fucked up.
You know that die in that girl's
pubic hair. That's, that's really, uh,
you need a hobby at that point. All
right. Why don't I stop judging people?
I asked her you fucking revenge stories.
Now I'm judging you. All right. Whatever.
This gets overrated,
underrated, a overrated karaoke.
Hate it. Terrible Song Sung
by people who can sing you,
which are usually fat chicks and gay guys,
and the off chance that you and your
drunk friends find yourself at a karaoke
bar singing eighties hair metal songs.
There's always those douchebags
and interrupt the fun
with a serious gay country
song. You know what I love about this guy?
He says, Garrick Karaoke is overrated.
Like people actually love it.
Okay?
Then he says that it's socks
and then in the middle of it,
he admits doing it.
But evidently when he and his douchebag
friends go up there and sing eighties
hair metal songs, that's
totally fine, you know,
but when someone comes up to sing us,
kick a country song, they're gay. Dude,
I hate to tell you this,
but you're part of the fucking problem.
I'm actually,
you know what,
actually if you sing an eighties
hair metal song and a karaoke thing,
I'm going to laugh my ass off.
And uh, I liked that better.
Just as long as someone doesn't go well,
what are the, what are the fucking tunes?
Those chicks I always end up singing.
Uh,
what does that song that guy sings
about losing his virginity? That oh,
what a knife
that sounded lay it is in La Vega and 63
for some reason women love that fucking
song. And uh, there's, there's
nothing worse than the female voice,
like 12 of them all singing
in a really high voice.
It's like a car alarm going off.
All right,
I think we're done for the week. And
Are we, what are we up to? 42 minutes.
All right. As bill is. This is
this podcast petering out here.
I think I'm doing too much reading and
not telling enough stories. All right,
let's, let's, let's read this
one here. Um, okay. Bill. Uh,
I'm almost 26 and a bunch of my friends
still love going to the clubs at night
and on weekends. Uh, now
I'm not sure that I'm,
if I'm getting too old for it or just,
or if I just can't stand people,
but I absolutely hate
going to these places.
I know as a guy supposed to
go in there and get girls,
but I just can't take it anymore.
No matter which place it is.
It always feels like she should get a
mandatory penicillin shout when you leave
because a group of sweaty skanky
people crammed into a room,
grinding to crappy techno
music is just disgusting.
That combined with the
guys with the sonic,
the hedgehog haircut just drives me crazy,
especially when they're the
ones getting all the girls. Um,
is it me or these places?
Truly horrific. And what stage,
uh, and what, and what age were you
officially the old fuck at the club?
Um, all right. All right, dude. Now you're
being too hard on yourself. First of all,
you're only 26 years old.
You're in the prime of your life.
You should be going out and talking
to women. You just doing it in a,
in a bar that's not you.
You know what I mean?
Like basically everybody's a douchebag.
Okay.
But you got to hang out with the
same kind of Douche bags so you feel
comfortable. You know what I mean?
Like me, I'm a loner psycho Douche bag.
So I used to hang out in dive bars and,
uh,
who the fuck am I kidding?
Did I that I don't think I ever
picked up a girl in the bar.
I always met him at gyms, amend them
on the subway a lot in New York.
Um, I, I meet them when
they're not ready. You know,
like women don't have
their guard up sometimes,
like on the train, they have that guard
up to get mugged, not to be hit on,
I guess. I don't know, maybe
I just felt like, you know,
I would never did well in those
singles bars. Like, you know,
it's almost like as a comedian, someone
goes, you're a comedian. All right,
say something funny. It's just like
you've ruined the moment. So I would,
I would still go out, just
find, uh, you know, find,
find the right place to hang out.
You can't hang it up to 26 unless you
live in the middle of Kansas and you might
as well fucking read a Bible and knock
up some broad and have eight kids and
vote for a fucking retard over and
over again for eight fucking years.
Okay. That was a little mean. All
right. Uh, question of the week. Uh,
Bill,
I was wondering how you handled two
shows a one night I was part of the lake
crowd tonight and you killed what was,
was it the same scenario in the earlier
show with a joke said bombed in the
earliest show where their jokes in the,
in the earlier show that bombed
that you skipped on the second show.
Uh, no. You know, if it bombed, I'm too
stubborn. I'm going to keep doing it,
but I'm doing two shows in one night.
I try to switch it up,
you know,
I just don't want the
waitstaff and everybody to
know exactly how am I actually
going to go. Um, because that's a big
thing on the second show and your three,
three days into your weekend gig. If, uh,
you see like the waitresses smiling and
stuff and laughing as they're bringing
drinks over to the table,
that's like one of the best
compliments you can get because, uh,
nobody sees more comedy or listens to
more comedy than comedy club waitresses
because as a comedian, if I see a
comic and I don't like what he's doing,
I can walk out of the room.
But as, as a waitress,
you have to, you got to keep going back
in, you know, and uh, so you can get the,
you know, so they get jaded
really quickly as far as like,
what's funny that I'm so, um, I don't even
know if I answered your question, but,
no,
I don't really,
I know what I'm going to start with and
I know what I'm going to finish with.
I don't really know what's
going to be in the middle,
but I definitely switch up the
jokes just so I don't feel like,
like that groundhog day thing
where everything's the say. So. Uh,
all right. There's that. All Right, Bill,
I've been listening to your podcasts and
I watched you perform because it's nice
to hear to someone use the
word cunt every five minutes.
You don't seem to curse as
much when you're performing,
but you're getting to be like,
uh,
some of the other dirty comics
out there on your podcast.
I think it's quite hilarious how you
use the word to describe anyone that's
pissing you off through
unnecessary though,
unnecessary most of the
time. Um, in addition,
I'll wait a minute. I already read this.
I already read this tonight. This is,
this lady asked me about Saint
Patrick's Day. That was from Cleveland.
I already read that. All right, so
I guess that is end of the podcast
for this week. Um, please
give me the feedback. What do
you think about the new, uh,
the new stereo sound?
I know I need to make some adjustments.
I know I might've been too close to it a
couple of times and I know that there's
like an echo in the room now and I'll
put some empty egg shell crates on the
fucking side of my walls, but
whatever. So, uh, so that's the deal.
I'm just to let you know,
uh, my upcoming gigs,
I'm going to be at Iowa state
this weekend, April 18th,
and that is a private show.
That show is only for the
students of Iowa state.
You need a student Id to get into the show
or
if you kind of look young
and you have a baseball cap,
maybe you can sneak your way in, but
you didn't hear that from me. Um,
the following weekend I'm going to be
at the funny bone in Columbus and the
weekend after that it'll be a
Caroline's in New York City. Um,
young Joe de Rosa will be for a
opening for me on both of those shows.
And then if you'll notice
on my, uh, my website,
I had to blow out a number
of dates. Tempe, Ireland,
Cleveland and Atlanta are
all being rescheduled.
And I can't really tell you why as of yet.
I'm going to leave you hanging.
How do you like that?
Huh?
Like one of those old fucking Batman and
Robin's when they're stuck in a machine
and they're going to fucking die and
you got to wait until next week. Yeah.
I can't really tell you. I can't
actually, I can't tell you for a minute.
I kind of a,
something may or may not be going on and
I needed to free up my schedule and at
some point actually in June
I'll be able to let you know.
So that's the deal.
That's the Monday morning podcast.
And if you like this,
the device I'm using is the Olympus
ls 10 this fucking thing is a,
it's pretty incredible and I'm going to
have a, a my own mic next weekend up.
Me and Joe de Rosa are
going to be continuing our
uninformed show as a podcast
on the uh,
myspace.com/uninformed radio.
And we're going to be using this
device with a couple of microphones,
and I think we're going to be doing an
episode next week and we're going to put
it up there and it's going to
sound lovely and that's it.
And I feel like I'm born
yet, so that's it. Everybody.
Thanks for listening and please keep the
questions coming and feel free to keep
sending me,
you know,
things from past topics and if you want
to do them for the, uh, the new ones,
songs,
your top fucking,
your top eight songs that annoy you
and shit in a sports that bugs you.
All right. That's it.
Everybody have a good one.